for the first time in more than three
decades in Iraq horses compete in a long
distance race
University student Fatima has come to
the ancient Sumerian city of nepor from
the southern city of Basra and she's
excited she's one of very few female
jockeys to take part
she says she's emotionally connected to
her four-year-old Arabian Thoroughbred
mayor is
we have been eagerly waiting for this
competition it had been my life's dream
to ride a horse until I realized it with
the opening of an equestrian Club in my
home City I hope to participate in more
competitions and represent my country
abroad
who I am
dress Mark is a breakthrough for
equestrian Sports in the country
during The us-led Invasion thousands of
state-owned thoroughbreds were lost
some were killed
others neglected or stolen and smuggled
abroad for three decades during war and
sanctions horse racing in Iraq was told
now nearly 100 jockeys representing most
Iraqi provinces are able to compete in a
single race
it's part of a drive by the country's
main equestrian organization to grow the
sport and raise standards
we're trying to salvage the golden times
our team of national Experts of many
years of experience in Gulf countries
despite all the hard times our country
has gone through we still have some of
the best breeds in the world
some pure Bloods are kept at the
federation's main facility in the
capital bardad
here horses are vetted to ensure that in
top condition to meet International
standards and compete abroad
Iraq used to be home to some of the
finest Arabian thoroughbreds
their value is judged by several
criteria including strong physique soft
skin wide eyes and large nostrils to
help them inhale as much air as possible
while racing but above all it's their
intellect an ability to respond to
commands that sets them apart
back at the racetrack the Iraq
equestrian Federation is hoping the
event will Revitalize the sport
and Fatima is calling on other Iraqi
girls to follow her lead
al-jazeera
in nepor southern Iraq